septembre rime cette année encore avec
rentrée mais une rentrée bien
particulière sous le signe de la coved
la rectrice là sur les collectivités
locales se tiennent prêtes
pourtant des questions persistent
notamment autour de la cantine plusieurs
options sont en discussion respecter au
plus bien soit la distance d'un mètre
entre chaque élève ou ajuster en
utilisant de nouvelles salles en
déjeunant d'un sandwich en classe ou en
mangeant en augmentant le nombre de
services pour échelonner les passages la
deuxième question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que le chant choral est possible
la réponse est oui mais masquée des
mesures sévères mais nécessaire selon le
directeur académique
l'idée c'est à la fois de le faire que
cette rentrée soit réussie mais aussi
d'anticiper cette hypothèse qu on espère
évidemment que ne pas devoir se mettre
en oeuvre qu'en pratique qui
consisterait à avoir ici ou là les
relocaliser une fermeture de classes ou
d'établissements
la rectrice de versailles se dit paré à
toute éventualité en cas de circulation
active du virus
si cette configuration devait se
produire à nouveau
eh bien nous puissions avoir une forme
et restera un hôpital de campagne
numérique vous peut-être une force
d'action rapide mobile numérique
et puis une autre hypothèse dont le
ministre a déjà parlé
également cette scène devrait fermer une
place un établissement une école bien
dans ces situations là les outils sont
tout à fait prêts les outils nationaux
ma classe à la maison la plateforme de
l'omni nos qualités
et comme le disait monsieur d'extraits
les collectivités locales sont tout à
fait prêtes à réengager un effort les
cours en présentiel sont obligatoires
pour justifier une absence il faudra
délivré un arrêt de maladie